hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter three of peridot's book
philosophy as a way of life
ends with a section called learning
how to read and at the very start of the
section he talks about the
multiplicity of different writings out
there
and the different levels that they're at
in terms of the spiritual
exercises that they're providing he says
there's a kind of unity
running through them and earlier on
in the chapter he's talked about a
number of different spiritual exercises
that directly involve reading and
and study so you can't really do
philosophy
as a way of life at least according to
the ancient models
without engaging in a lot of reading and
it's not something that you read
once and then you get the stuff down and
then you put the books away
no you're continually going back to
reading and
rereading in part because that's how you
in fact
study and so for those who are
you know more into practice and less
into reading there's a lot of really
useful stuff that a doe brings to light
here
calling out of ancient philosophy we
should mention as well
that practices of writing could also be
quite important as spiritual exercises
but here he's primarily talking about
how you engage
other people's writings that are
available and so the question that we're
really asking in this subsection of the
chapter is
how should we approach philosophical
writings
and this is a really interesting one
because as he points out
much of what we've learned from today's
academic philosophy with some exceptions
of course
would actually take us off track it
would teach us how to read
as bad readers as readers who
can't get quite what is going on who are
more interested
in getting through the material or
you know just give me the arguments or
the main points
right and that's to lose sight of
something quite
important and so there are a number of
different points that he makes
that i think are very important and
helpful not just for
doing philosophy as a way of life in the
present but also for understanding
how you know hado himself approaches
these things and how ancient
philosophers
and their students would approach this
so the first thing
he tells us is we really need to
consider
writings whatever they happen to be as
situated or
motivated and part of this is we have to
think about them
as coming out of a school like he says
they're products of a philosophical
school in the most concrete sense of the
term
in which a master forms his disciples
trying to get the
trying to guide them to
self-transformation and realization
so the written work is a reflection of
pedagogical
psychological and methodological
preoccupations now some are more than
others you could think about epictetus
as discourses and then caridian
he didn't write those down there the
results of his teaching
and of his student areas who thought
well this is really important stuff
i'm going to write this down we're going
to to keep this
we could also think of like you know
epicurus's lists of
sovereign maxims or golden sayings or
whatever
whatever framework you want principal
doctrines is another way to translate it
and the vatican sayings
putting together lists of those sort of
sayings sort of like epictetus and
caridian as well
those are very important that's a
genre of literature is it meant to be
like the same thing as a philosophical
treatise no not not exactly it's serving
a
a different purpose as a dough is going
to tell us
every philosophical text is
from some particular framework
he says when we read the works of
ancient philosophers the perspective
we've described should cause us to give
increased attention to the existential
attitudes underlying the dogmatic
edifices that's the buildings or
structures
we encounter now that's not to say that
it's exclusively motivated in that way
but that we should never lose sight of
that
so he tells us whether we have to do
with dialogues as in the case of plato
class notes as in the case of aristotle
treatises like those of platinus
commentaries like those of proclass and
we might multiply
all sorts of other things think about
letters
think about other other ways that well
inscriptions
all those other types of genres he tells
us that
a philosopher's works cannot be
interpreted without taking into
consideration the concrete
situation which gave birth to them now
what do we mean by the concrete
situation we don't mean
you know what was epictetus doing on
thursday you know june 2nd
between three and four it's not that
granular you could say
but we do have to think about well what
was he doing what kind of pupils was he
teaching
the stoic literature provides us with
some great examples here right
epictetus was teaching people in his
school as was his teacher musonius rufus
the lecturers of whom we have some uh
remainders of and some fragments
marcus aurelius was not doing that
marcus aurelius was managing an
empire and writing a book literally to
himself
that we call the meditations seneca was
also managing
affairs trying to get a spoiled brat
emperor to not be the complete garbage
person that he was that's nero right
to be less of a schmuck right but also
to provide
some guidance to his epicurean friend
lucilius
in what we call the letters to achilles
or moral letters or letters from the
stoic depending on which
edition you have each of those is a
different
concrete situation plutarch with his
treatises
sent to different people for different
reasons all of these
have a function to them so we want to
try to think about that we want to be
cognizant about that
right another key thing is
every philosophical work is in some
sense a monologue
one person is talking or you know
you could say in platonic dialogues
you've got different people talking but
it's talking to us
right but implicitly every single
philosophical work according to
doe and he's totally right about this if
it's a philosophical work
it is implicitly a dialogue we can enter
into dialogue
with it as we do with aristotle when
we're going
through his treaty seas and lecture
notes and trying to piece them all
together
or when we're reading platonic dialogue
so like he says
the dimension of the possible
interlocutor is always present
within it this explains in coherencies
and contradictions with mo
which modern historians discover with
astonishment in the works of ancient
philosophers
in philosophical works such as these
thoughts cannot be expressed according
to the pure
absolute necessity of a systematic order
it takes into account the level of the
interlocutor
the concrete temple the logos in which
it's expressed
and so he goes down from there and this
is bringing up this logos
is another important point
tells us every logos every discourse
right every every argument you could say
every train of thought is indeed a
system in some sense but
putting together the totality of logoy
of any given author is not itself a
system
so putting together all of aristotle's
books on a shelf
does not give you an aristotelian system
as such despite what
later systematizers would like to do
with it usually debasing it in the
process right
same thing with platonic dialogue same
thing with
you know senecas various letters and
work
same thing with with others as well
even when a work appears to be
completely systematic
ido says well we have to be a little bit
on guard about that
he brings up this idea of different
starting points corresponding to
situations and
he brings up aristotle and this is great
because
if you read aristotle's works one of the
things you'll see him saying
most often is let's consider this from
another
angle or beginning from another starting
point so he he takes a phenomena
and he zeroes in on it from this
perspective and then he
zooms back out and says let's look at it
now from over here
oh let's let's now go back here and look
at it this way
those are all motivated in one way or
another we don't always know exactly
what the motivation is
but we know that aristotle thought for
example it was important in discussing
politics to discuss household management
and that meant discussing slavery
and that meant talking about whether
slavery could in any in a sense
be natural or just by force
aristotle by the way considered most
slavery to actually be
against nature and to be by force now
later
uh interpreters of aristotle misused him
to argue that he
thought that slavery uh particularly
that you discovered that the new world
was actually just by nature
distorting aristotle in the process so
you know different starting points
correspond to different concrete
situations
another key thing is that like like
adobe's going to say you you write
different works for different kinds
of readers they come at different
levels of spiritual development he uses
platinus's
anad's as an example with this some of
the things are more advanced than others
some are less advanced so you assign
these to people differently we can say
similar things with plato's dialogues
some of plato's dialogues you're like
why does socrates make such a bad
argument well because he's making a bad
argument for a dummy
who he's talking to who can't recognize
a bad argument even though you
you know careful reader might be able to
recognize it
so those are all important aspects and
then
finally this is something i think is
really quite
important to take into account
there's this idea that people have about
philosophy and about reasoning in
general and debate
that you you put out your arguments
and by themselves arguments are
convincing or they're no good and when
you spend time
looking at arguments you come to realize
that they all require something
you don't have any perfect pure argument
that does all the work needed to
construct a world view
or get people to be motivated by
themselves there's always something else
going
on involved there and
ado says we should not forget
that many a philosophical demonstration
so now we're going beyond just arguments
demonstration derives its evidential
force
not so much from abstract reasoning
which is not to say it doesn't use
abstract reasoning but
not so much from abstract reasoning as
from an experience
which is at the same time a spiritual
exercise
so he says you know this is the case for
the plutinian demonstration of the
immortality of the soul
let the soul practice virtue he said and
it will understand
that it is immortal right and he gives
an example of augustine as well and the
trinity
augustine thought that the human mind is
an image of the trinity
and you know you can make it better or
or
worse right we might actually think
about renee descartes
in this respect is descartes prevent
presenting you with
pure argumentation no the meditations
are spiritual exercises as he tells you
in the work and in his letters about it
right
so this is not something that should be
gotten rid of in philosophy and that's
what ancient philosophers realized
but modern philosophers lost sight of
this should actually be embraced and
understood
that it may take some level of spiritual
development before certain
demonstrations really
click or get traction
or whatever metaphor you want to use for
that
so these are all things to keep in mind
in terms of
how we should approach philosophical
writings
of antiquity i would say that this also
goes for any sort of philosophy as a way
of life
in medieval thought in modern philosophy
even down to the present and perhaps how
we also
ought to read ado himself
you